on a tendance à les cacher mais eux
aussi méritent toute notre attention le
pied s'entretient pour être en bonne
santé beaucoup de gens négligent il y a
beaucoup de consultations en dernière
minute en urgence des ongles incarnés
des durillons qui sont là depuis des
années qui sont très douloureux qui
empêchent de travailler ou de faire du
sport correctement et du coup ils
consultent et ils se rendent compte
qu'en fait en juste en inst pédicur sont
soulagés pour éviter ces situations
l'Union Française pour la santé du pied
propose depuis 2003 des dépistages
gratuits dans les ivelines c'est la
troisème année que des podologues
participent à la journée nationale une
séance chez un spécialiste permet de
dépister mycose ongle incarné problèmes
cutané mais aussi problèmes d'arthrose
au niveau des genoux hanches ou encore
du dos on poser un diagnostic sur
l'appareil locomoteur donc c'està-dire
que le pied est vraiment en relation
avec l'appareil locomoteur dans son
ensemble c'estàdire le genou le dos la
hanche même au niveau cervical et en
travaillant avec des élément de semelle
on peut travailler sur ses articulations
et soulager des des pathologies au
niveau de de ces zones du corps donc en
2012 seulement 30 % des Français
consultaient un podologue en 2014 ils
sont 41 %. moi j'ai pas de souc vraiment
particulier donc voilà mais j'ai eu des
conseils concernant parce que je ne vais
jamais chez chez le pédicure et
apparemment il faut y aller une fois par
an pour moi c'est pas vraiment la
prévention là en l'occurrence puisque
disons que je suis ça' ça m'handicape
énormément pour marcher depuis à peu
près un mois donc c'est plus que de la
prévention bon je dis l'année prochaine
je j'espère que je reviendrai pour de la
prévention selon une étude de
l'Observatoire national de la santé 65 %
des Français ont mal au niveau des pieds
mais une consultation chez un podologue
coûte 27 € et n'est remboursé que
partiellement par la sécurité
sociale